bis zuletzt zumindest schien es ja so
als gäbe es für die AFD im Grunde nur
eine Richtung die AFD 17 + 2 die Partei
gewinnt ihren ersten kommunalen Amtssitz
ja AFD erneut mit einem Rekordwert ja
Rekordwerte für die AFD die anderen
Parteien wirken und wirken da ziemlich
ratlos gegen sich zum Teil gegenseitig
die Schuld jetzt aber zeichnet sich ab
das eine Partei womöglich die Chance hat
das hier zu schaffen die AFD mit ihren
Wählerinnen und Wählern zu halbieren
gemeint ist allerdings nicht Friedrich
Merz und seine CDU sondern ich habe es
vermutlich schon empfanden in einem
Titelbild erkannt Sie hier bzw ihre
Partei eine Sarah Wagenknecht verteilt
ob sie das wirklich schaffen kann den
Siegeszug der AFD stoppen das heißt
wovon das abhängt ob die nötigen
Voraussetzungen erfüllt sind das gucken
wir uns jetzt mal ganz genau an
[Applaus]
also wovon hängt ab ob eine Sahra
Wagenknecht Partei die AFD stoppen oder
sogar halbieren kann drei
Voraussetzungen erste ziemlich
offensichtlich davon ob es sie geben
wird die Partei weil ganz genau noch ist
Sarah Wagenknecht nach allem was man
weiß Mitglied der LINKEN nur dafür sie
sich politisch schon lange nicht mehr zu
Hause zwischen machen wir eine Politik
die vor allem in
großstädtischen studentischen Kreisen
überhaupt akademischen Kreisen sehr gut
ankommen mag aber das sind eben oft auch
junge Leute aus sehr gut situierten
Elternhäusern die sich nicht über die
soziale Frage politisiert haben sondern
über Klimafragen an die Rassismus
Sexismus also das was heutzutage oft als
Links gilt ja da kann man natürlich
sagen wenn man sich so wenig
repräsentiert fühlt von seiner Partei
dass man rausgeht nur eins geht nicht
dass wir uns Monate lang mit dieser
Frage beschäftigen
deshalb kann ich nur sagen wenn Leute
das Vorhaben denn sonst ist es schnell
machen sollen nicht die Partei ewig
quälen also die sie ihre Partei quälen
oder entscheidet sie das jetzt ruckzuck
in ein paar Tagen in ein paar Wochen
also ich gehe davon aus dass innerhalb
des nächsten
Dreivierteljahres maximal ein Jahres die
Entscheidung so oder so fallen wird und
auch bekannt sein wird gut im Grunde
muss die Entscheidung spätestens jetzt
im Sommer irgendwann fallen wenn sie
nicht schon links gefallen ist weil die
Idee wäre ja vermutlich nächstes Jahr
zur Europawahl anzutreten die im Juni
und das geht natürlich nicht von heute
auf morgen es gibt bürokratische Hürden
deswegen braucht das alles ein bisschen
Vorlauf eines aber steht jetzt schon
fest du scheint es zumindest ein zurück
zu den linken wird sozusagen nicht nicht
geben oder schöner ausgedrückt mit der
vorrätische und hat die
Scheidungspapiere eingereicht lebt aber
noch im selben Haus und jetzt wird es
interessant gesagt hat das nämlich sie
hier Carola Rakete die neue
Hoffnungsträgerin der Linken
Parteispitze oder Rakete Carola Rakete
fragt euch jetzt vielleicht die kenn ich
doch irgendwoher ja bekannt geworden ist
sie als seenotretterin als
klimaaktivistin und wurde jetzt als
Spitzenkandidatin der Linken für die
besagte Europawahl nächstes Jahr benannt
und
Nominierung hat Wagenknecht vermutlich
in ihrer Einschätzung bestätigt dass die
Linke ihre Schwerpunkte verschoben hat
für Carola Rakete ist nämlich vor allem
wichtig dass die Linke auf allen Ebenen
eine klare antifassistische und
antirassistische Haltung einnimmt dass
dieses madnat was ich dann vielleicht
mal habe
mit der klimagerechtigkeitsbewegung der
migrationsbewegung rückgekoppelt ist ja
sind in der Tat ziemlich genau die
Schwerpunkte die Wagenknecht falsch
findet sie ist ja zum Beispiel für
migrationsbegrenzung sieht das Thema
Klima nicht im Zentrum linker Politik
sondern setzt ihren Schwerpunkt ganz
klar auf finanzielle Interessen derer
die wenig haben und beim Thema Russland
Krieg wo die Linke zumindest
einigermaßen gespalten ist es
Wagenknecht von Anfang an konsequent
nachsichtig mit dem Aggressor mit
Russland also in Summe ein zurück zur
Linken nicht vorstellbar bleiben zwei
Optionen Option 1 sie zieht sich zurück
aus der Politik Option 2 sie macht sie
gründet ihre neue Partei ich finde dafür
spricht einiges erstens sie hätte sich
sonst diesen ganzen Streit sparen können
mit ihrer noch Partei zweitens sie hat
schon mal durchgezogen von paar Jahren
vielleicht könnte ich erinnern da wollte
sie eine Bewegung Gründen Aufstehen hieß
die war zwar ein ziemlicher Flop aber
hat gezeigt wenn sie sich mal was im
Kopf setzt dann sieht sie auch durch das
so eine Partei Gründung auch eine große
organisatorische Aufgabe wäre auch
finanziell darauf gehen wir gleich noch
ein aber gehen wir erstmal davon aus sie
macht's dann wäre um auf unsere
Ausgangsfrage zurückzukommen die erste
Voraussetzung um den Siegeszug der AFD
zu stoppen erfüllt folgt Voraussetzung 2
hätte eine solche Wagenknecht Partei
ausreichen
Wähler Potential
ja da zeigen die Zahlen ein ziemlich
klares Bild schauen wir erstmal auf die
Imagewerte von Wagenknecht aus unserem
ZDF Politbarometer da liegt sie auf
einer Skala von -5 bis +5 bei
-1,4 dieser absolute Wert ist aber gar
nicht so entscheidend spannender ist was
die Forschungsgruppe noch herausgefunden
hat nämlich wenn man sich mal anguckt
wer Wagenknecht gut findet und da zeigt
sich da da von AFD Anhängern wird sie
schon länger deutlich besser bewertet
als von Anhängern der Linken nämlich
plus 0,2 von den Linken Anhängern plus
1,4 von den afd-anhängern ziemlich
klares Bild also und das deckt sich mit
einer Erhebung von Insa mit Blick auf
Thüringen warum Thüringen da ist
nächstes Jahr Landtagswahl und da die
AFD in einen besonders starken Rückhalt
vor kurzem wurde er ja auch im Landkreis
Sonneberg wir haben anfangs die Bilder
gesehen der erste AFD Landrat gewählt
mit absoluter Mehrheit wie also würde
eine Liste wagen Knechten offiziellen
Namen gibt es natürlich noch nicht also
ob es nach der Liste heißt oder
parteiwagenknecht wie auch immer wir
aber würde eine solche Partei hier
abschneiden laut Insa so 25 Prozent
hieße aus dem Stand stärkste Kraft vor
der AFD die ohne eine solche Liste
Wagenknecht selbst stärkste Kraft wäre
und zwar mit einigen Abstand mit Blick
auf unsere Ausgangsfrage stoppt
Wagenknecht die AFD ist daher zusätzlich
vor allem eine Zahl relevant nämlich die
hier in Klammern wenn wir uns die noch
mal genau anschauen vor allem bei der
AFD minus 10 steht da heißt die AFD
würde 10% Punkte schlechter abschneiden
als bei einer Wahl ohne eine solche
Wagen nicht Partei sie würde also 10 %
Punkte an Wagenknecht verlieren und
diese -10 sind wenn man es mal mit den
Veränderungen bei den anderen Parteien
vergleichen der mit Abstand höchste Wert
heißt also das vor allem AFD Wähler zur
Wagenknecht Polizei abwandern würden ja
natürlich kann man jetzt erstmal sagen
wir wissen nicht was kommt richtig und
wenn man mal so in die Partei reinhört
was ja auch einige aus unserem
ZDF-Hauptstadtstudio regelmäßig tun dann
hört man wie das alles runtergespielt
wird ja ein paar Prozentpunkte wird das
kosten aber die Wagenknecht dieser
mental auch gar nicht so belastbar der
ist vor kurzem Burnout und überhaupt
solche Prognosen die dürfen man eh nicht
überbewerben das stimmt sagt auch Sie
Sarah Wagner parteienforscherin die das
Potenzial einer möglichen Wagenknecht
Partei wissenschaftlich analysiert hat
mit allen möglichen verfügbaren Daten
sie sagt mit Blick auf diese Thüringen
Prognose auch Wahlabsicht und wählen das
sind zwei verschiedene Dinge aber in der
Tendenz hat sie und ihr Forschungsteam
was ganz ähnliches rausgefunden nämlich
das sowohl Leute die schon AFD gewählt
haben als auch solche die damit
vielleicht geliebäugelt haben ist aber
noch nicht getan haben also die zum
potenziellen wählerkreis der was ihr
gehören das von denen ganz wesentlicher
Teil sich auch von der Wagenknecht
Partei angesprochen fühlen würde das
bedeutet auch dass
die AFD zum ersten Mal seit ihrer
Gründung eine WählerInnen Mobilisierung
weg von der Partei erleben wird bisher
in deutschen Parteiensystem haben wir
nur gesehen dass WählerInnen von der
Linken von einer SPD auch von anderen
Parteien zur AFD gegangen sind sprich
die AFD wird in einer komplett neuen
Position sein also Zwischenfazit hätte
eine Wagenknecht Partei genug Potenzial
um der AFD gefährlich zu werden
eindeutig ja ob es ein halbieren wird
unklar aber richtig weh tun würde dass
der AFD in jedem Fall genau
es sei denn
[Musik]
Koalitionsoptionen ja es sei denn Sahra
Wagenknecht käme Parteigründung und
Wahlerfolg vorausgesetzt irgendwann auf
die Idee mit genau dieser AFD zu
koalieren weil wenn man das Potenzial
bei der zusammenrechnet wäre durchaus
denkbar dass beide Parteien gemeinsam
eine Regierung stellen können zum
Beispiel in Thüringen Betonung auf
könnten bleibt die Frage würden sie auch
wollen schauen wir erstmal auf die AFD
die will rechtsextreme warte mal da habe
ich das ja Rechtsextremist björn höcke
hat Sahra Wagenknecht schon zu Beginn
des Jahres zu berufen ich bitte sie
kommen Sie zu uns und jüngst sagte
Thüringens AFD Co-Chef Stefan Möller
Zitat wenn ich mir Wagenknecht
Positionen anschaue dann scheint mir
eine Partnerschaft mit ihr am
wahrscheinlichsten also die AFD würde
wohl wollen bleibt die Frage würde auch
Wagenknecht wollen im Juni hat sie bei
einer Veranstaltung der Diskussion gegen
umarme und armutsgefährdete Menschen das
hier gesagt ein Großteil dieser Menschen
sieht bei keiner Partei mehr eine
Interessenvertretung und wenn überhaupt
bei einer und das ist die Tragödie dann
ist es die AFD Tragödie sagt sie hieße
demnach ja wenn das Ihre Bewertung ist
dann wäre es noch die viel größere
Tragödie wenn sie mit genau dieser
Partei paktieren würde und sie dadurch
am Ende sogar ein
Regierungsverantwortung hießen würde
aber auch wenn Sie das jetzt so andeutet
da ist auch es gibt eine große
Schnittmenge zwischen AFD Wählerschaft
und Wagenknecht Fans insofern ob sie
dann am Ende tatsächlich eine
Zusammenarbeit ausschließt wir wissen
nicht was kommt
spannend natürlich zum Abschluss es gibt
noch eine zweite Partei die unter einer
neuen Wagenknecht Partei leiden würde
nämlich die Linke selbst deren Fraktion
im Bundestag könnte sogar sofort
zusammenbrechen je nachdem welche
Abgeordnete Wagenknecht mitnehmen würde
und auch einige Wähler würden ihr ganz
sicher folgen allerdings wäre der
Wählerverlust wohin nicht so groß wie
bei der AFD sagt die
parteienforscherinnen weil die die
Wagenknecht Position teilen sich zu
großen Teilen schon von der Linken
verabschiedet haben in den letzten
Jahren trotzdem für eine Partei die
viele ortsnah in der 5% Hürde ist würden
natürlich auch geringe Verluste schnell
ziemlich existenziell werden eine
Hoffnung die daher hier wie bei der AFD
viele haben das Wagenknecht ist
organisatorisch gar nicht hinkriegt
sprich ihre Partei falls Sie sie gründet
dann auch überall an den Start bringt
weil kann ja auf Dauer keine one
womanshose sein dazu bräuchte es ja
unter anderem viel Personal also man ja
auch 16 Landes verwenden man braucht
mindestens 20 Büros das muss auch alles
bezahlt werden das klingt alles so
einfach ist aber schwierig ja und bei
wagenknechts Bewegung Aufstehen das
überhaupt nicht gut funktioniert mit dem
organisatorischen darauf verweist auch
die parteienforscherin ob Wagenknecht
daraus gelernt hat könnte man noch nicht
sagen der Zeitpunkt allerdings jetzt sei
möglicherweise ziemlich günstig
zumindest für den ersten Aufschlag mit
Blick auf das womit es dann losgehen
würde nächstes Jahr wir haben
Landtagswahlen in den ost-bundesländern
wie die Thüringen bei denen wir auf
jeden Fall auch Nachfrage nach einer
solchen Partei sehen und dann eben auch
Europawahlen und da könnte sich quasi
dann die Möglichkeit haben mit relativ
wenigen Ressourcen noch möglichst viele
Menschen anzusprechen und hätte dann
quasi Übungsfläche bevor Sie in einen
möglichen Bundestagswahlkampf einziehen
würde
[Musik]
apropos
Bundestagswahlkampf bin ganz
zuversichtlich dass die AFD bei der
nächsten Bundestagswahl nicht viel
anders abschneiden wird als bei der
letzten das hat jetzt natürlich auch so
ein bisschen was ironisches dass diese
Prognose des Kanzlers am Ende eintreten
könnte dann Sarah Wagenknecht die sich
ja gerade mit ihren Russland Positionen
völlig unmöglich gemacht hat bei den
ampelparteien auch bei der Union des nun
ausgerechnet Sie Sarah Wagenknecht
insgeheim deren Hoffnungsträgerin ist
mit Blick auf die AFD wenn natürlich
niemand offen sagen aber klar ist aus
Sicht der ampelparteien und der Union
wäre eine zersplitterte Protest
Wählerschaft Wut Wählerschaft natürlich
deutlich besser als eine geeinte ja
lohnt also sehr genau hinzuschauen was
Sarah Wagenknecht machen wird wir
bleiben für euch dran ich hoffe ihr
bleibt bei uns dran lasst uns gern ein
Abo da vielen Dank für eure Interesse
bis zum nächsten Mal